[Music]
hello
welcome welcome to the table i'm so glad
that you all are here today
and um if you are new here a special
welcome
special welcome to you so um if you if
this is your first second third time we
have a few little visitor cards there on
the world's tiniest table in that
hallway and um
it's just we just love to get to know
you and connect with you so
um
if you would after the service you can
you can do that if you feel so inclined
we'd love to to be able to connect and
um
also i want to give an announcement
before we uh kind of continue into to
worship and all that so um basically
just one next week a week from today
we're having um a child dedication
and um
a collective gasp from the children up
front
dedicating us to what um
so
uh so basically what this is so as a
community we don't really do like um
child baptism you know that's kind of
just not in our tradition or our wing of
the church we don't do that so instead
we do hey sweetie um we do um what we
call child dedications so it's basically
it's sort of a commitment both of the
parent and for the community to be able
to um just commit to raise the child in
just a christ-centered atmosphere so
we're kind of committing to that as as
parents can do that and then the
community's also committing to like
love those children well so um you can
either fill out again a card there and
just say you know child dedication and
i'll follow up with you with more info
or anyone who's online um you can just
you know send us a message or something
and um
we'll get you to be a part of that so
all right i think um i think that is
everything so let me go ahead and um
pray i want to say this prayer
over you also if you'll bow your heads
close your eyes
lord god
we gather as your people
to worship to pray
rejoice
weep laugh and connect
we gather to come home again to you and
to ourselves
speak lord
your children are listening
speak lord and open our hearts and our
minds
speak lord and transform us
in the name of jesus christ we pray
amen
hey guys why don't you stand with us
we're gonna get started in worship
noel's gonna lead this first song and
for anyone who is new with us tonight i
just wanted to take a moment just so
that you know who is up here in front of
you who's leading um because we're a
community it's not we're not up here to
perform a concert for you but we're here
to gather with you in worship so this is
josh this is his wife joe
and maggie
noel and my name is mindy and we're
really glad that y'all are with us so
please join in because it's a communal
experience all right um and i believe
that god wants to um comfort us and
speak to us i believe he wants to share
in this creative moment with us so caleb
good to see you
all right let's go ahead and get started
so
[Music]
is
you cannot find us
there when we rise
[Music]
[Applause]
we are yours forever
[Music]
from the
[Applause]
[Music]
we are yours
we are forever
found forever even in the darkest nights
we'll sing because your love has set us
free
[Music]
it's all around us
us it's all around us
[Music]
we will sing because your love has found
us even if the darkest nights will sing
because your love has set us free
[Music]
all right you kids y'all are dismissed
and ready to go to your class we'll see
you after
i just want more
more of you
god
i just want more
more of you
got
[Music]
lord i'm ready
to open up my heart
to receive not in heart
but the fullness of who
you are
lord i'm ready
i just want more
i just want
more of you
i just want more
[Music]
lord i'm ready
i just wonder
i just want
more of you
god i just want more
i just want
[Music]
more of you
i want more of you
[Music]
i need more of you
i want more of
[Music]
i need more of you one more time
come and reach into my heart
[Music]
i need
i just want more
[Applause]
[Music]
come and heal every part lord
i want more of you
i just want
more
views
we're going to move into our
prayers of the people
so go ahead and read along with me
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community and all of those who
live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and will to conserve
it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick for the widow
and orphan
for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and oppressed the
unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
psalm 40
says i waited patiently for the lord to
help me
and he turned to me
and he heard my cry
he lifted me out of the pit of despair
out of the mud
and the mire
he set my feet on solid ground
and he steadied me as i walked along
he has given me a new song to sing
a hymn of praise to my god
[Music]
i won't be overwhelmed
give me vision
to see things
you know just
[Music]
to see things like you do
that i love to
where my health comes from
give me wisdom
you know just what to do
[Music]
forever all days
give me vision
to see
things from
you know just
[Music]
[Applause]
i will love you
again
[Music]
i will love you
[Applause]
[Music]
lift up hallelujah
forever all my days hallelujah
[Music]
[Applause]
we look to hallelujah tonight
for all the burdens that we're carrying
for any confusion
anxiety
doubt
depression
for any struggle that we have over our
mind our heart our emotions
our body
god we look to you tonight
for the questions we have with parenting
or relationships or partnerships or
marriage we look to you tonight god
because you are the god that takes us
out of the mud and the mire and sets our
feet upon a rock
you are the god
that takes us out of confusion
and brings clarity and peace
[Music]
you are the god that reigns over death
and depression and speaks life and hope
and healing
over us
[Music]
so god whatever it is that we've walked
in this room with
we trust you to meet us there
we trust you to hear us
we trust you
to give us vision and wisdom where we
need it god
this world is broken
and it is hurting
and it is hard sometimes to live
in such a broken place
it is hard sometimes to remember that
there is still good
[Music]
that there is still a god that loves us
it is hard sometimes to see past our
current moment
and to remember that you are a god
beyond time
beyond these walls
beyond this
city or this state or this nation
you are bigger
and your perspective is greater
[Music]
our world can be so consuming god
i can be so wrapped up in my own issues
my own struggles and problems
so god i ask that you would lift us
above that and help us to see things
your way
[Music]
speak life into our dry bones
we look to you tonight god
would you speak to us would we listen
for your voice
would we hear you
would we know you
[Music]
jesus we ask all these things in your
name
amen
thank you guys for worshiping with us if
you want to sit down and turn to the
people around you and say hello welcome
them
and brett will get us started on our
message
all right
good evening grace and peace
um looks like we got a
we're a small group tonight but
i'm my heart is full
my heart is full um
i want to um welcome all of you and uh
that includes those joining us online
we um love you lots you are you're not
forgotten
and um and also like i mentioned earlier
anyone here who's new are just kind of
you know making their way into the
community thank you for being here um we
long to be just a hospitable people you
know like this is who jesus was jesus
welcomed
uh everyone pretty much didn't really
place boundaries on that the only folks
he kind of made uncomfortable were super
religious people
which is kind of interesting
church folk
so um it's all to say welcome uh so we
are actually we're beginning um a new
series tonight
titled hearing god
hearing god i'm i'm kind of um yeah i
wonder um i don't know what that phrase
brings to mind for some of you maybe uh
you know
i don't know it just depends on what
wing of the church maybe you you've come
from if you didn't if you're not
familiar with you know christian
world and theology and all that then
maybe just means nothing it's kind of
like oh what a weird idea you know um
but for others it's we have all sorts of
preconceived notions um
around it and we really we um we got the
idea for this series actually if you
joined us um at easter
um it was the the whole theme was how
jesus calls us by name
and um it just kind of got me thinking
like i want to i want to unpack that
more you know i want to go deeper into
that so um really the message tonight
will serve as
just kind of like a whole extended
introduction um to the to the series as
a whole it'll be a four week series um
so we'll kind of do the intro tonight
and then the next three weeks will be
like we'll talk about how kind of more
specific ways that we hear god
through scripture and community and
kind of emotion and feeling and things
like that so um anyway it should be it
should be a good time so the the title
of the message tonight is a listening
life
and our primary text is first kings 19.
though before you read that i want to
kind of catch you up a little bit um
with sort of what's happened you know
before in the story because otherwise i
don't know if it'll really make all that
much sense so um the story basically
goes that um
elijah this is this is he was a great
prophet maybe or one of i should just
say one of the greatest prophets um the
jewish people have ever known and uh
this is kind of a famous moment in his
um life so basically um it's like this
famous showdown he had with uh the
prophets of ba all as their as this this
kind of idol this idol was was known and
um
so the basically that what he had
noticed was people were turning from
kind of the one true god you know the
lord and we're following this and
worshiping this idol and he had enough
of it so he challenged the prophets of
all to this like showdown and so he said
uh whoever can cause um fire to
fall and can from like heaven and
consume a previously sacrificed bowl on
altar like just burn it up uh that team
wins basically that that religion right
it's sort of like it's sort of a test of
you know who's the true god so uh so it
they like all the people come out i
guess it's like the equivalent of like
the religious super bowl or something
you know everyone was curious about
what's gonna happen you know and so uh
so all the people gather
and the prophets of baal they go first
and so they like there's the bull and
then they like they start praying their
ritual prayers and doing their ritual
dances and they even like basically for
hours go by and it's not really working
no fire is falling so they start to like
cut themselves with knives and the blood
is like flowing and i mean it's sort of
violent and a little bit crazy and but
no fire no fire whatsoever um so
finally elijah uh he has his turn
and so he tells the um
people to get water and they literally
soak the sacrifice with water you could
tell he's like you know kind of
laying it on you know soak it down with
water and then he just prays one prayer
he's like lord
you're the true god you you are god
there's no one like you so
basically prove yourself and boom this
fire just comes like not only um like
just kind of slowly but no it's just
like evaporating just like boosh gone
and the people i mean the jaws are on
the floor you know it's just like oh my
gosh
and it's you know it's this moment of
like it's like a high point in um
elijah's life really it's like it's a
moment of great you know religious
victory
um however just one problem uh was that
the queen at that time queen of israel
was um jezebel and she was a worshiper
of baal
and so um
she was none too happy about this so she
orders elijah to be executed
and you know like many times in our life
many a sermon has been preached on the
theme that elijah's greatest mountaintop
moment
then becomes his lowest which isn't that
kind of how it often goes in our life
it's just like you know the adrenaline
is flowing and it's like yes victory you
know just whatever it is the
breakthrough you got the job you know
whatever just like the high point turns
into
you know and this is exactly what
happens to him it's like this moment a
great religious victory and then
suddenly he's literally fleeing for his
life to the desert
and he's exhausted
he's alone
he's discouraged
and he he just he just needs a word from
god so that's where we pick up the story
first kings 19
um second half of verse nine
and the word of the lord came to him
what are you doing here elijah
you replied
i have been very zealous that means like
passionate for the lord god almighty the
israelites they've rejected your
covenant they've torn down your altars
they've put your prophets to death with
the sword i'm the only one left
which by the way was not true
but sometimes it can feel that way can't
it
i'm the only one left and now they're
trying to kill me too versus
said
go out and stand on the mountain in the
presence of the lord the lord is about
to pass by
and then a great and powerful wind
tore the mountains apart and it
shattered the rocks before the lord but
the lord was not in the wind and after
the wind there was an earthquake but the
lord was not in the earthquake and after
the earthquake came a fire
surely the fire right but
no the lord was not in the fire
and after the fire came a gentle
whisper
when elijah heard it
he pulled his cloak over his face this
is something people often did when they
were encountering the glory of god it
was a sense of
covering
pulled his cloak over his face and then
he went out and he stood at the mouth of
the cave
then a voice said to him
what are you doing here
elijah
sometimes
we just need to hear a word from god
now this this phrase um
hearing god
it's um
it's a bit of a puzzling one isn't it
have you ever wondered about this phrase
hearing god sometimes christians you
know talk quite a bit about like well
the lord was just talking to me the
other day and he said such and such then
i was like well i don't know about that
and did it you know and it's like
they're just they're carrying on some
sort of magical conversation with god
you know and it's like okay
and uh and then you know how does it
feel to be you you know then it's sort
of like oh well god doesn't talk to me
like that but of course i'm not going to
say that publicly so i'll just nod along
like oh yeah oh that's great i love when
god does that you know
um
this honestly this phrase hearing god
now before i get into i should say i do
think god can speak that way like
sometimes it is that clear and maybe
some sort of audible voice you know
whatever that is like so the exception
rather than the rule that is yeah um
which we'll get more into this but but
this phrase hearing god
for me it was puzzling
it was um
honestly very frustrating
for many many years in fact um for some
of those of you who know my story i i
very
very close to leaving the christian
faith in my um kind of
early to mid 20s
and um this phrase
hearing god like there were many reasons
but this was like top ten for sure maybe
top five
hearing god have you heard from god
today
are you hearing god what's the i heard
of one pastor he would just walk out of
people and say what's the word of the
lord this morning he would just tell
that to people what's the word of the
lord that you know it's like um you know
you're supposed to come up with
something i guess
um
hearing god what is this talking about i
i
i went all of my late high school years
i went into my early 20s
um and i there was actually it was
really my first year of college that i
said like i okay i want to figure this
out like i'm not here apparently people
are hearing from god i'm not hearing
from god so i want to hear from god
so i committed to there was a little
prayer room at my college i went to a
bible college that's why there's a
prayer room and uh there's a little
prayer room
a
dank
dark little it was like musty probably
mold i may have gotten something in that
for it wasn't good
but i can still man but the smell if i
walk back in that place it would just be
like oh chills you know um it was this
messy place and i committed i'm gonna
spend at least 30 minutes
sometimes i would spend an hour two
three even four a day whatever time i
had you know i was a college student i
had some time
and i was just spinning and i what i was
doing there i was committed
to hear
from god
i was gonna freaking do it
like i was tired of this like well i
mean maybe you know i don't know i know
i like i want i wanted to hear from god
and uh what happened honestly um it
didn't really work i i spent day after
day after day maybe an awesome spiritual
pastor would be like and then on day 33
breakthrough i did you know um i mean i
just know it start you know i just i go
well this is why i eventually almost
left the faith because i just thought
well this isn't this isn't working you
know
it's not working for me i'm not hearing
i'm not hearing anything because i
honestly i just i had no um i heard no
booming voice
i had no like
jarring spiritual experience you know i
just
didn't happen for me and so i just i
just grew by by the end of that that
year i was just so
frustrated
so discouraged disillusioned i just i
don't know
i felt like a failure you know i was
supposed to hear from god get a word
from god i just you know i
i wasn't
and um
and so what happened is i assumed that
god was silent
because
um
because i had a cert i had a certain
i didn't realize i had it but i did i
had a certain um interpretation i had a
certain expectation of what that phrase
meant
and for me it was quite literal
you know and in other words um
i kind of went about this the wrong way
because i i was expecting or basically i
was looking for god
um
in a way where like i would receive a
word from him
that would well that would be like the
wind in elijah's text right i expected a
word from god that would be like the
wind that would shake the cinder block
stones of that little prayer room
you know i i wanted to i was looking for
god in the way where um where i would i
would feel
um
i would i would feel a certain emotion
you know that would be that would shake
me like an earthquake
you know i was expecting to hear from
god with the with the fire of intense
feeling where i would man i would walk
out of that prayer room glowing like
moses of old
that's what i was looking for and what
did i miss
what did i miss in the process
i missed
the insight that elijah received
that can god
speak in those ways well sure
but that's the exception rather than the
rule
generally god speaks in
a whisper
god speaks and whispers in many ways
this is um
this is really the the heart of our the
whole series
tonight
don't get overly caught up looking for
god in the loud in the extraordinary
learn to discern
the whispers
see the problem is not that god is not
speaking leading guiding teaching
instructing
the problem is we're looking for it to
be
amazing you know blow the roof off this
place
you know
instead of
as we'll look at later this still small
voice
saying this is the way
walk in it
you know i love this um i love this
metaphor
of um
hearing god
because there's something about i don't
know just the something about the mode
of hearing
that is very you know it's just more
receptive than the other senses like if
the phrase was um you need a touch from
god now people will say that but that's
not like as popular you know probably
because it's just so much more tangible
in a way you know um that's the thing
with the the sense of touch like it's
sort of like you when you touch like
you're kind of in control
you know what i mean like if i touch
them it's like hands it's easy um even
eyes seeing it's almost like something
goes out no one can stop you know i'm
just looking and it's like there's a
part of me it just kind of goes out and
like
almost touches with the eyes you know
and then of course taste is similar it's
like i go i possess i consume you know
i'm i'm in the driver's seat you know
with a lot of those senses but hearing's
interesting you know if you think of
someone who's losing their hearing what
do they do
you know they're like
kind of trying to
turn you know isn't that a little bit
different than like touch is like oh
easy
got it you know what i mean but hearing
is often you know you see someone kind
of turn their head and hand behind the
ear you know trying to discern i think
this is this is why the metaphor of
hearing god i think is so is the right
one i think it's really really good so
here just as we're starting this series
i want to give you a definition like
what on earth is he talking about
hearing god what do i mean and honestly
what do most christians mean when
they're talking about this um here's our
definition hearing god is the metaphor
christians have used down to the
centuries to describe the way that god
through the holy spirit is continually
teaching guiding instructing and leading
us from from within the depths of our
being
this is what
people mean when they're when they're
hearing from god
um
god is speaking from within
and that doesn't mean it's not true or
real
you know of like oh so it's fake no no
it's not fake but it's just it's it's
different than a audible literal you
know
well good morning god well good morning
brett it's good to see you again you
know god what's going to happen today
well
there's a heads up let me give you a
heads up three big things happening
today you know like it's no
no
no god speaks to us from within the
depths of our own
being
um
and and again you know
god speaking audibly can happen
um elijah it happened in that story
moses is another example
mary mother of jesus
people can have kind of in that case
because it was an angel but you know
people can have those kind of encounters
but generally speaking
um it's it's it's a discerning of the
still small voice now my hunch is that
probably those of you here tonight
you're having maybe one of two reactions
on the one hand um
maybe there's a sense of like okay yeah
yeah actually that kind of makes
a certain amount of sense you know like
oh this is what people
this is what they mean when they were
saying oh i heard from god this morning
you know and so it's like okay that
makes me feel a little better i maybe i
could do this but then another part of
you is probably thinking okay
yeah but still the problem is i don't
even know if i'm hearing anything in the
depths of my own being you know like
even that seems a little bit silent i
don't know i wouldn't know if god is
speaking what know what that sounds like
wouldn't know how to discern the depths
of my soul or what i like oh
how well and here's the thing brad maybe
i'm speaking on your behalf but here's
the thing like uh
god i thought
god though god is up there
you know i mean god is god god is
isn't he in the heavens
you know and then like i am here
so if it's not like some sort of audible
boom thing like wait how
you know how does this even work um and
and i actually i want to speak to that
because i think um this is part of our
problem is that how we've imagined how
god relates to us
um
goes right to the heart of i think why
we struggle to believe that we're in
touch with god or hearing from god in
any way
and this is why you won't
hear me use the language of the
supernatural very often
those of you who have heard me preach
maybe i've used it once i don't know i
might not have ever used the word
supernatural
and um
and this is why
um
by the way i know many of you are hot
right now
sorry
the ac is just struggling
what can we say
i'm not hot i'm fine don't worry
sorry
um
okay so let's talk about this so the
supernatural you know what the language
of the supernatural kind of introduces
is this idea of like um of two realms
you know so there's like you know the
natural
where we live
you know i mean nature
the natural
and we are you know we're kind of um
we're kind of
somewhat cut off kind of removed maybe
because of sin or something like that
you know but we're like we're just and
then where does god live god is in you
know the supernatural
and so in order for us to hear a word
from god or connect with god or anything
what has to happen
um god has to invade
can you kind of see how that language
works like got it god and even people
will pray lord and you know invade this
place god you know invade my life you
know or something like as though god is
absent from this place and your life
you know what i mean
um i think this language is quite
unhelpful it's supernatural because then
because then the idea is like god you
know he's mostly kind of like an
absentee parent you know he's sort of
distant and cold
but occasionally he comes around you
know he decides to meddle in some way
you know like okay okay i'll do a
miracle you know and even this idea of
miracle in this sense you know i mean
where god comes in like
i'm gonna meddle now with things and
like do with you know but then i'll kind
of retreat or god's gonna speak a word
so he's like okay i'll come and with a
big booming voice like say a thing and
then i god's gonna retreat back to his
home you know or something um
this yeah i think i think this is
problematic even uh even the way i was
thinking of that that old term in uh
football the the old hail mary
i think this is people we don't praying
for god to intervene on behalf of their
sports team you know it's a little bit
of
this idea maybe he'll come and adjust
the path just a little bit so that the
dallas cowboys can win you know and it's
this idea of like god please come and be
where you are not for just a moment you
know um that this is i'll just say
christianity's greatest minds down to
the centuries have said um well many of
them have said this isn't a great way to
imagine it um this isn't a good way to
understand how god interacts with the
world instead let's look at an example
this is the apostle paul from acts 17 28
this is i think a better way
he says this in him in other words god
in god we live and move and have our
being
that an interesting way to put it
in god
you live
always already
in god you live and you move and you
have your very like what's being like
literally your existence at all
which means everything
you do like is not somehow separate from
god
interesting like to think um the breath
you're breathing right now
you're like probably weren't aware of
before i said right now
even that is like god's
grace
and goodness to you
a sustaining of your very
being see there is no place called
nature the natural where god is not but
somehow it just kind of runs on its own
no
no we we are picked your metaphor we are
suspended
by god we are enfolded by god we are
surrounded by god we are always deeply
present and connected to god this is um
this means you know there's no breath we
can take that's somehow separate from
god and there's no thought you can think
that is somehow like utterly just
alienated and distant from god i'm not
saying god causes every thought to come
in your head you know but like
i'm saying even the thoughts
you think are not not somehow
completely disconnected
you are deeply this is what we might
call um a participatory view of reality
as opposed to like a supernatural
natural view a participatory we
participate in god we are enfolded
connected to
god all the time
um
this is why god only has to whisper
isaiah 30 21 puts it today whether you
turn to the right or to the left your
ears will hear a voice behind you saying
this is the way
walk in it
this is the way walk in it now again you
could read that in a very literal way
like well i don't hear any voice it's
like no no don't
don't take what is poetry and metaphor
overly literally
right again hearing god is the metaphor
christians have used down to the
centuries to describe the voice
the voice within you say the voice what
voice
um let's do don't make this overly kind
of elaborate and crazy like have you
ever um have you ever um
had like a moment where you had a
certain opportunity before you and it
looked fantastic
i mean everyone around you was like go
for it yes and something within you was
saying
nope
you ever had that kind of moment
have you ever um
had an experience where
you deeply wanted to say something like
a word like
and suddenly
you just knew that you knew you were not
supposed to say that thing
now those are more negative on the
positive have you ever gone into a
situation and you're like oh my gosh
i have no idea what to say
i have no idea i don't oh gosh i'm
almost sick
i'm almost sick to my stomach over this
i do not know what and you get into
actually the bible talks about this
um
jesus even said when they bring you
before the like judges and
rulers and people who are like there to
persecute you you know don't worry about
what you're don't worry about what
you're going to say
the words will be given you and have you
ever had that kind of moment maybe it's
not like you're facing persecution you
know but it's just you go into a
situation you don't know what to say and
suddenly it's like the voice comes to
you and you're like saying things and
you're like oh my gosh how did i know
that and people maybe even give you
feedback like wow
that was so helpful how did you know to
say that well i'm just a genius you know
no
no you're you and i are we're not just
geniuses
it's
it's the it's the voice of god
it's the voice of god i i often find
this even with my um
sermons sometimes
um and actually anyone who does anything
creative
you ever had this moment where you go
into the thing and you don't know
you're like what am i doing right now i
don't know what i'm
gonna write or what i'm gonna create or
this song i'm gonna try to write a song
or do a thing or and then suddenly i
don't know it is like i mean actually
even the the greeks and other people had
a worthless like the muse
the you know i mean they're trying to
say like the some
spirit or something like comes over you
and like takes you and like starts and
it's almost like the words don't like
come from you they come to you
you know what i mean like from somewhere
else
like what is that
like that
that's it god is speaking this i think
this is what's been interesting it's
been happening to us our whole life
we just didn't know what to call it
maybe we even took credit for it like oh
yeah i'm just awesome you know like
no no no this god is present
god is speaking to you um i love this
quote this is from theologian rowan
williams he said this the christian life
is a listening
life
because what if instead of just like
when i'm being creative
or when i'm going into a hard
conversation
you know but what if all the time
we could be in a heart posture of saying
god what are you up to
what are you speaking
how are you leading me what are you
trying to teach and show me
because the truth is i think
this is happening like
all the time
why well this comes back to the
participatory view
right because god is deeply present to
you
and he's taking you somewhere
right he's he's got a loving um
he's in loving relationship with you and
he wants you to grow and develop into um
the character and image of jesus christ
his son
and so he's taking you on the journey
um as another quote this is from
uh john milbank
and i'll close with this he says this um
god is not a dinosaur
or a remote star
then he unpacks what he means he says
dinosaurs and astral bodies i guess that
means star
are still things
even if they are big
and ominous
god is not a thing
and just for this reason
he may be equally thought of as small
and intimate this is partly why he
showed us that he is in uh he is also a
baby as he is incomprehensibly vast and
sublime and if god is not a thing
then he does not affect us
selectively occasionally
or even like persistently
but rather
all the time
and in every possible
respect
can you hear the participatory view
happening in that like if god is not a
thing like just a being a big being you
know like superman
um if god is like
the ground of being itself god is the
very source of everything that is in you
then god is impacting you
speaking to you present to you
all the time so the question is not well
why isn't god saying anything to me how
do i get god to speak to me
that's the wrong question right which is
why i had my disaster of a prayer room
experience well god's not even here
god's not even showing up god's dad god
hasn't said a darn thing to me and i've
been in here six months and you know
no no no no
no the question is what was god saying
and was it actually
whispers
that i was just
i was missing
so that's that's the series that's where
we're going to be going is kind of
taking that idea and then applying it
to different
um areas
and really my goal is that by the end of
the series we would be a community
um that expects to hear
from god
it just expects it um but not
necessarily in a oh you know always in
some loud extraordinary amazing you know
kind of way but um
all the time
in every possible respect
um
so as we as we come to the table of the
lord today this is
kind of um
well this is one way
that we hear from god
that we
connect we participate and while it's
true that god is always present to us
there is something beautiful and
precious about
coming to receive the body and the blood
of christ because it's this it's i mean
it's a talk about a holy moment i think
every moment's a holy moment
but this is for sure a holy moment you
know this is a moment where we remember
again our connectedness
through bread and through wine but we
remember again our connectedness to the
one who gave his life for us who loves
us just right where we're at
and who even now is speaking and
inviting us into deeper relationship
so let me invite you
to the table and then some folks will
come up and we'll serve it
so this is the table
not of the church
but of the lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more
so come
you who have much faith
and you who have little
you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come
come because it's the lord himself who
invites you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should meet him
here
come to the table
[Music]
this last song um
but it's actually
drawn from a prayer that's very very old
the prayer of saint patrick
and
i wanted to just read part of that to us
real quickly
it says christ be within me
christ before me christ behind me
christ beside me
christ to win me
[Music]
to guard me
it just feels so rooted and grounded and
number two
it just reminds me that some of our
struggles are age-old
people were needing prayers like this
way before we were right
and
when brett was telling me about his
message and what he was going to be
sharing it reminded me of the scripture
in first john 4
and
it says
let us love one another for love comes
from god everyone who loves has been
born of god
and knows god
and it struck me so differently in light
of what brett was sharing because
i've read that scripture i love first
john and i reread that on a regular
basis it's just one of my favorite books
of the bible i feel like it's so
tangible and practical and real i just
love love
and it's so good so go read first john
this week if you want some fresh
inspiration in your life but what i
loved about it is that last line
those who love god know him i mean sorry
those who love know god and it didn't
say those who love god know god it said
those who love
know god
and it just was like this eye-opening
thing to me where we can get into all
the nitty-gritty theology and not that
that's not important but when i'm seeing
someone love i am experiencing god and
when i am truly loving someone else when
i'm putting myself second to someone
else
that's knowing god that's understanding
him so this big complex subject of
hearing him and knowing his voice and
when he's speaking to me remembering
that sometimes it's simple acts of
doing the right thing loving someone
being patient with my child who is
exasperating me and i'm so worn out you
know whatever the thing is
that little act of love
that in and of itself is a form of
hearing him because that's knowing who
he is knowing
the god of the universe right here in
this small tangible moment so anyway i
just wanted to share that with you as we
go into this song would you guys stand
with us and even if it's new for you
it's new for us too so
join in wherever you feel comfortable um
and
i just want us to remember that this is
an age-old prayer that will hopefully
ground us
and center us as we go into our week and
remember that he
is speaking always just inside of us
as i rise
strength of god
[Music]
go before
look upon
as i wait
heart of god
satisfied
and sustained
as i hear
the voice of god
lead me
[Music]
christ be all around
me around
[Music]
[Applause]
be me around me
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
i defend
before
and behind me
in every eye that sees me
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
christ be all around me
[Music]
[Applause]
me
excuse me
is
[Music]
every
moment
[Music]
[Applause]
you're shed
for
every moment
[Music]
in every eye that sees me
cries be all around
[Music]
sees me
so me for being with us tonight
and um if you need prayer
um i'm gonna be at the back and um i
would love to pray
with you
um so just just let me know
and also if you're visiting again um go
fill out a card um afterwards we'd love
to be in touch with you
and then finally if you're interested in
that child dedication for kids like 12
and under it's usually the age we'd be
happy to we'd love to have them be a
part of that so
all right let me send you out with this
benediction
it says this
you are a child of god
and this is true on your best day
and it's true
on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved
you are worthy
and you
are accepted
just as you
are and go filled with god's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
gifts of grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact with
go in peace
darkness